[Music]
so basically for most of psychology's
history the focuses i has been on on
what's negative about people on
diagnosing illnesses on depression on
problems and in a lab since like the
late 90s there's been a huge emphasis on
positive psychology on studying what's
right about people on studying human
flourishing and kind of the fundamental
root of most of positive psychology
research is the assumption of what's
called hedonism which is basically the
pursuit of pleasure the avoidance of
pain and so there's a lot of researchers
in the positive psychology space or
there's a few who feel like positive
psychology research is very limited
because basically what one of the core
assumptions is is that positive emotions
lead to positive outcomes and that kind
of goes against a lot of different types
of philosophies philosophies like
stoicism or Buddhism or even you know
more spiritual practices that talk about
how sometimes actually negative
experiences sometimes negative emotions
produce some of the best outcomes and so
avoiding solely avoiding negative
challenging difficult emotions is
probably actually one of the worst
things a person can do who's seeking
growth you know there's a really good
poem by Douglas Malek and he says he's
talking about trees but he says good
timber does not grow with ease the
stronger the wind the stronger the trees
the further sky the greater length the
more the storm the more the strength and
so essentially strong trees they require
difficult circumstances they require
strenuous environments that force them
to adapt deeper roots and so if you're
always avoiding negative or challenging
emotions there's obviously going to be
some problems internally you know you're
not dealing with things and yeah so I
think that there's a lot of problems
with positive psychology and kind of the
fundamental assumptions anticipation is
a huge component of psychology basically
what most people most people anticipate
that an event or a thing is going to be
more intense than it actually is
it's why people wait a long time to jump
in a swimming pool is because they think
that it's going to be an intense
experience and so if you anticipate that
a task is going to be difficult you're
probably going to
procrastinate or you're gonna put off or
you're going to have emotional
challenges going into it but if you just
recognize that you're going to adapt to
it very quickly once you actually get
into it motivation kicks in so that's
another one of the things that holds
people back is is that they feel like
they have to be motivated first when
basically motivation happens once you
start doing something action precedes
motivation so basically a Harvard
researcher and I forget his name off the
top of my head but he says that it's a
lot easier to act your way into feeling
than to feel your way into acting and so
if you spend a lot of time anticipating
an event it's gonna hold you from doing
it but if you just actually start doing
it motivation will kick in you'll start
to actually get accustomed to it you'll
start to develop capacity will adapt to
it
so I think it can hold people back but
obviously a positive anticipation can be
a great thing so like there's this idea
that you know you're always changing but
that doesn't mean you're always growing
so if you want to grow you must change
but just because you changed doesn't
mean you grew or you became better so
you could you could obviously change
your habits and I think that as human
beings were always adapting and changing
based on what's around us so we're
always replacing old habits with new
ones but that doesn't mean that you're
creating positive habits if you want to
create positive habits I don't I mean it
doesn't always have to be hard but I
think generally it's gonna be somewhat
difficult it's going to take take
growing out of that so yeah I would say
yeah you can change habits through a
hedonistic perspective doesn't mean that
you might be developing the ones you
want
[Music]